[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic pulsar et étoile à neutrons depuis
la terre le ciel nocturne est parsemée
d'une multitude de points lumineux pour
la plupart il s'agit des toiles
d'immenses boules de plasma en fusion
qui rayonne d'une lumière intense de par
leur température élevée bien qu elle
fluctue légèrement à cause des
perturbations de l'atmosphère la lumière
des étoiles est plutôt stable et ne
varie pas en intensité mais dans les
années 1960 en observant le ciel dans
d'autres longueurs d'onde
les astronomes découvre des points
bryant qui clignotent au cours du temps
ces points semble t m des oscillations
extrêmement régulière dont la luminosité
pulse de façon métronomique
on les baptise pulsar pour comprendre
d'où viennent ces pulsars il va falloir
nous plonger dans la vie d'une étoile
on s'intéresse à une étoile dix fois
plus massive que notre soleil
au cours de sa vie notre étoile brûle
son carburant par un procédé de fusion
nucléaire
le coeur de l'étoile libère ainsi de
l'énergie vers l'extérieur ce qui lui
permet de s'opposer à la pression de la
gravité et de rester stable mais à la
fin de son existence alors qu'elle n'est
âgée que d'environ 100 millions d'années
notre étoile finit par s'épuiser
elle est venue à bout de tout son
carburant et la fusion nucléaire en son
coeur s'arrête
l'étoile n'est plus en équilibre plus
rien ne vient s'opposer à la gravité du
coeur qui commence alors à s'effondrer
sous son poids
tandis qu il rétrécit le coeur de
l'étoile se comprime sa température
monte à plusieurs milliards de degrés et
il se met à tourner de plus en plus vite
générant un champ magnétique de plus en
plus puissants au bout d'un moment le
noyau devient si dense que les
particules qui composent la matière sont
forcés de fusionner les électrons
pénètre dans les noyaux d'atomes et se
combine avec les protons ils forment
ainsi des neutrons et rejette au passage
une quantité faramineuse de neutrinos
[Musique]
soudain la taille du coeur devient si
faible que les neutrons se heurtent les
uns aux autres stoppé net le coeur ne
peut plus se comprimer davantage la
contraction s'arrête brusquement et les
couches extérieures de l'étoile sont
violemment soufflé par l'ondé de choc et
les neutrinos qui les traversent
l'étoile explose c'est une supernova
l'explosion de l'étoile laisse derrière
elle un gigantesque rémanents un nuage
de gaz et de poussières interstellaires
qui donnera peut-être naissance un jour
à de nouvelles étoiles
mais après sa mort le coeur de l'étoile
est toujours là il s'agit désormais
d'une minuscule boules de matières
formes et de neutrons comprimer les uns
contre les autres c'est un cadavre des
toiles qu'on appelle étoile à neutrons
[Musique]
lors de leur formation les étoiles à
neutrons peuvent se présenter dans
différents systèmes
beaucoup des toiles par exemple orbite
en couple dans des systèmes binaires
autour d'une autre étoile après la mort
de l'une des deux étoiles
l'étoile à neutrons qui lui succède va
parfois continuer de tourner autour de
sa partenaire de même si l'étoile était
initialement entouré de planète
celles ci vont parfois continuer de
tourner autour du cadavre
[Musique]
une étoile à neutrons est un astre
incroyablement dense qui renferme à lui
seul la masse de plusieurs soleil dans
quelques dizaines de kilomètres c'est
l'équivalent de la masse de pluton
comprimé dans la taille d'une bactérie
si on l'a compris mais légèrement
davantage la gravité prendrait le dessus
et l'astre se transformerait en trou
noir
l'étoile à neutrons est également
extrêmement chaude pour certaines la
température de surface peut dépasser
plusieurs millions de degrés celsius du
fait de sa petite taille elle tourne
très vite sur elle même en ce compris
mon le coeur de l'étoile qui l'a formé à
accélérer jusqu'à atteindre des vitesses
proches de celle de la lumière
une étoile à neutrons peut effectuer
près de 1000 rotation sur elle-même en
l'espace d'une seconde une voiture dont
les roues tournent aurait aussi vite se
déplacerait à cinq mille kilomètres par
heure à la surface d'un tel astres la
gravité est insoutenable et donne lieu à
d'étranges phénomènes de relativité
tout d'abord le temps est fortement
dilatées si un astronaute se posait sur
l'étoile à neutrons
il ne vieillit ray que de dix mois pour
chaque année qui s'écoule sur terre
malheureusement pour lui les forces de
marée sont également colossal la
différence de gravité entre sa tête et
ses pieds et son million de fois plus
forte que l'attraction terrestre
il finirait instantanément spaghetti
fier enfin l'étoile à neutrons dévie les
rayons lumineux autour d'elle pour ben
la géométrie de l'espace temps comme un
trou noir
elle crée ainsi des effets de lentille
gravitationnelle qui déforme l'image des
objets environnants et qui nous
permettent même d'observer sa face
arrière
[Musique]
la structure interne d'une étoile à
neutrons est encore mal connue petit et
très distantes
il est impossible d'observer leurs
compositions depuis la terre il faut
donc s'en remettre aux mathématiques qui
décrive la façon dont se compressent la
matière par la physique quantique en
surface une étoile à neutrons et très
probablement entouré d'une fine
atmosphère pas plus épaisse qu'un cheveu
sous laquelle se présente une surface
parfaitement lisse la gravité
aplatissant toute aspérité qui
dépasserait sous sa surface
l'étoile à neutrons possède tout d'abord
une croûte principalement solide formée
de noyaux d'atomes et d'électrons libres
à mesure qu'on s'y enfonce
la pression augmente et les noyaux
d'atomes commencent à se combiner avec
les électrons pour former davantage de
neutrons la forte pression permet de
stabiliser ces noyaux plus lourds qui se
désintégrera d'ordinaire à force les
noyaux d'atomes eux mêmes commencent à
se combiner entre eux et s'agencent pour
former des amas encore plus gros plus en
plongée dans la croûte
plus la compétition entre les
différentes forces gravité
électromagnétisme et interaction forte
va pousser ces regroupements de matière
à se comprimer entre eux les noyaux
fusionnent alors pour former des
structures plus longue en forme de tube
plus profondément encore ces tubes sont
poussés les uns contre les autres et se
regroupent pour former un feuilleté de
couches superposées les unes sur les
autres
enfin ces couches se regroupent entre
elles et se referment petit à petit
laissant apparaître des creux dans un
liquide de neutrons ces différentes
structures en réseau géométriques qui
apparaissent à la base de la croûte
formeraient l'un des matériaux les plus
résistants de l'univers des sortes de
noyaux d'atomes à grande échelle que les
chercheurs ont baptisé pâte nucléaire
leur géométrie rappelle en effet des
gnocchis des spaghettis ou encore des
lasagnes ce qui permet aux scientifiques
de classifier ces structures de façon
intuitive
si l'on décide de plonger plus
profondément encore on dépasse les
limites de la croûte et on entre dans la
zone où la pression est la plus forte
c'est le noyau de l'étoile à neutrons le
coeur d'une étoile à neutrons est une
région extrêmement difficile à décrire
car elle repousse les limites de nos
modèles les conditions de pression ils
sont tellement intense qu'entre en jeu
des principes de la physique quantique
notamment les particuliers sont
tellement rapprochées qu'elle se
repoussent par le simple fait de ne pas
pouvoir se superposer c'est ce qu'on
appelle le principe d'exclusion
cette forme de matière dont la structure
est régie par le principe d'exclusion
est appelée matière dégénéré la matière
dégénéré est encore très mystérieuse il
existe plusieurs hypothèses très variés
quant à ses formes les plus extrêmes
il pourrait simplement s'agir de
neutrons collés les uns aux autres mais
les neutrons n'étant pas des particules
élémentaires ils sont eux mêmes composés
de quark
on peut imaginer que sous de telles
pressions les quarks se séparent pour
former un super fluide ou même un plasma
de quarks et de gluons dans les
propriétés seraient très exotique
l'intérieur des étoiles à neutrons reste
encore une énigme sur laquelle les
chercheurs travaillent d'arrache-pied
[Musique]
lors de sa formation l'étoile à neutrons
a acquis un champ magnétique extrêmement
puissant sur terre des scientifiques
sont capables de générer des champs
magnétiques de plusieurs dizaines de
tesla qui sont suffisants pour faire
léviter des objets et même des êtres
vivants mais une étoile à neutrons
génère un champ magnétique plusieurs
millions de fois plus puissant un tel
champ magnétique est si intense qu'il
est capable d'altérer les fluctuations
du vide quantique lui même il peut ainsi
conférées à l'espace autour de lui des
propriétés de réfraction la lumière qui
le traversent
peut être déviée se dédoubler où se
recombiner
la façon d'un aimant le champ magnétique
d'une étoile à neutrons s'échappe par un
pôle nord s'enroule autour de l'astre et
y rentrer par un pôle sud
l'étoile à neutrons possède ainsi un axe
magnétique qui dans la plupart des cas
n'est pas aligné avec son axe de
rotation quand elle tourne sur elle même
le champ magnétique de l'étoile à
neutrons est entraînée par cette
rotation ce qui crée des fluctuations
très importantes qui vont se propager à
la vitesse de la lumière
à proximité le champ magnétique va
piéger la matière et la forcer à rester
autour de l'astre créant ainsi un disque
de matière al'inverse à grande distance
le champ magnétique varie tellement vite
qu'il s'ouvre et accélère les particules
chargées vers l'extérieur de cette façon
l'étoile à neutrons va produire deux
faisceaux d'ondés électromagnétiques
extrêmement puissante qui s'échappe le
long de son axe magnétique à la manière
d'un phare cosmique
ces faits sont rayonnants vont balayer
l'espace de façon périodique et émettre
un signal dont les oscillations seront
visibles par les astres qu'il balaie
lorsque la terre se trouve sur le chemin
de l'un de ces faisceaux on observe un
petit point qui clignotent dans le ciel
c'est un pulsar
[Musique]
depuis les années 1960
des observations de pulsar sont
répertoriés et classifiés en fonction de
leur fréquence d'oscillation plus
l'étoile à neutrons tourne vite sur elle
même plus on reçoit sur terre des
pulsations rapide on peut ainsi
catégoriser différentes populations de
pulsars certains tournent très vite sur
eux mêmes à presque 1000 rotations par
seconde
si pulsar très rapide se présente pour
la plupart dans des systèmes binaires en
orbite autour d'une étoile
ils ont pu accélérer jusqu'à ces
vitesses extrêmes en capturant une
partie de la matière de l'étoile
al'inverse d'autres pulsar tourne plus
lentement sur eux mêmes au rythme de
quelques tours par minute
la rotation d'une étoile à neutrons est
extrêmement stable
sa précision est comparable à celle de
nos meilleures horloges atomiques
mais au cours des milliers d'années de
son existence
l'astre va perdre de l'énergie
magnétique par rayonnement et
gravitationnelle dans la courbure de
l'espace-temps progressivement les
pulsars perdent de la vitesse et
finissent par n'effectuer que quelques
tours par minute
au cours de ce processus de
ralentissement la surface de l'astre va
s'ajuster à la diminution de la force
centrifuge et prendre une forme plus
féeriques de façon très brusque la
surface va s'écraser de quelques
micromètres
en l'espace d'un millionième de seconde
ces phénomènes ont pour effet
d'accélérer légèrement la rotation de
l'astre de façon très soudaine les
différentes populations de pulsar sont
classifiés dans un diagramme où figurent
leur vitesse de rotation en fonction de
leur rythme de ralentissement on y
retrouve les pulsars binaire qui tourne
très vite sur eux mêmes et sont très
stables ainsi que les pulsars plus lent
qui ralentissent au cours du temps
depuis la terre on observe des
rayonnements de tous types
la plupart des pulsars émettent des
ondes radio mais d'autres peuvent
émettre des rayons x plus énergétiques
de par leur rotation et leurs champs
magnétiques voire parfois des rayons
gamma
certains de ces pulsars possède des
champs magnétiques si puissant qu'on les
appelle des magnetar ils émettent des
gerbes de rayons x et de rayons gamma
très intense de façon irrégulière
ce qui rend leur comportement très
complexe à décrire
[Musique]
on connaît aujourd'hui près de 3000
pulsar au sein de notre galaxie
malheureusement la grande majorité des
étoiles à neutrons reste inobservable
depuis la terre pour la plupart leurs
faisceaux très restreint ne traverse pas
notre ciel et nos télescopes actuelles
ne permettent de détecter que les plus
tard les plus actifs ces astres sont
encore mystérieux et très peu compris
les soulèvent des questions astronomique
physiques et mathématiques qu'il reste
encore à résoudre mais les pulsars
présente un intérêt sans précédent dans
le monde de l'astronomie
il pourrait permettre de vérifier la
théorie de la relativité générale en la
poussant dans ses limites les plus
extrêmes permettre également de
comprendre le comportement de la matière
sous des pressions aussi intense ils
nous fournissent des horloges cosmique
d'une stabilité hors du commun et leurs
études pourraient renfermer des indices
quant au comportement des ondes
gravitationnelles indirectement les
pulsars pourrait nous renseigner sur la
nature de la matière noire et la
présence potentielle de trous noirs
primordiaux dans l'univers il représente
également de très bons repères pour
aider nos satellites à s'orienter dans
l'espace et c'est autour d'un pulsar que
furent découvertes les toutes premières
exoplanètes
[Musique]
vous